[Inaudible].
It turned out. I had half a million.
[inaudible] yeah, no, it totally
[inaudible] for luck of VC [inaudible] nets there.
The Taver Kamali we're here with
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
Ah. [inaudible]
uh, Hmm.
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
Or
[inaudible] [inaudible].
You check about tiddly and yet if it, if it's named an eat,
I'm not saying up or for me, my,
most of their volume in Costa pool.
So most of my mouth tiddly.
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] did count them in Syria.
Also, do I own the name? Right?
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] oldest chance. [inaudible] man.
Yeah, man, that [inaudible] behold
[inaudible] was coming full chapter better.
[Inaudible].
Totally so shipped to do the infrastru. Picasso
are IO
[inaudible] [inaudible].
It'll scare the Beatles there.
[inaudible] [inaudible] well, thanks.
[inaudible] I can Sue [inaudible] who go live with
[inaudible] or call me, or email me at the room. So
[inaudible] because of calc.
Totally. Yes. You're crushed. Really sharp. Listen, man.
And tiny I'll call it
[inaudible].
Yeah. And also back story. Yeah.
[inaudible] and what then the other [inaudible] it mean
[inaudible] me then I would leave.
Yeah. [inaudible] um,
we'll get for VIN near how the home today they'll do Y.
I want to get
[inaudible] there's a store. There's going to be [inaudible] social
that artificial
[inaudible].
We don't share in the duties list.
[inaudible] [inaudible].
Yo, ask us the
dead stole ARB at better rapport there
[inaudible] [inaudible] from [inaudible] capital splits, man. Bobby,
how you would fish
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] FEMA for factory.
So they're hearing you say my law or they're hearing a free
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] I did. And [inaudible]
I, I, for them, uh, for the other
[inaudible] in government for me, just for me to do not see [inaudible] uh,
or there are, so there are some
[inaudible] men, if we, you have to smack no.
[Inaudible] tell me that was, that was there. The sorry, the ABA look.
Oh, Oh, there you are.
Yeah.
Or a or Nissa?
[inaudible] [inaudible] LMR.
[inaudible] dude.
[Inaudible] uh
[inaudible] um, so
[inaudible] uh
[inaudible] so I'd have him on induction
[inaudible] but I think it all there. Yo.
[Inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] smack ma man,
the, the man, your, your ticket outside your
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] man.
[inaudible] [inaudible] tall hitter.
Would that Arab STEM [inaudible] he would just go full. Cool.
You just got out of us. Would they come on? [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
Yeah, the American. So
[inaudible] had the head breast RVR feeds that Udemy,
the log-in breast Armenia.
Those go through a lot with me at the
[inaudible] and the man that cut the small
[inaudible] the water
[inaudible] long somebody's [inaudible] familiar.
[inaudible] around there.
Oh, the underground. All right. I'll tell some outside.
[inaudible] so my Dean, their whole cuisine
[inaudible] conduit.
[inaudible] absolute
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible].
Oh.
Among yeah. Among [inaudible] familiar.
Uh.
The
[inaudible] on [inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] um,
do IO Milan died in Las Vegas. Mila died. Okay.
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
I did it.
Awesome. I say, Oh dude. Yes, we'll do a millionaire.
[inaudible] stomach.
[inaudible] [inaudible] I mean, for me again, it, you lost the, for a target,
so they have to buy the
[inaudible] or spend the [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] in I'd simply
[inaudible] yeah.
Hi Heidi.
[inaudible].
No, they clot are four tickets. I thought [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
Oh, Liam, not Elks. I'm literally.
I'm not a man. [inaudible] he?
[inaudible] some coffee now.
[inaudible] I'd say I want to take out. I have the, Oh, it's okay.
Yeah.
Bye.
[Inaudible] [inaudible] would they come and say how you pull back up?
[inaudible] feel hard. [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] and Ellie, some cats.
That mean me.
[inaudible] [inaudible] intersect.
[Inaudible] so I do glove.
Oh, absolute, absolute.
[Inaudible] do do it guided for Noah.
Um, it ended up on me and Dr.
Duke. We were hams Nirvana gunshots and I'm in the shower.
We were here with, uh, [inaudible]
uh [inaudible]
or do
[inaudible] Davies E T E N T.
So can skip her mother after the [inaudible]
so that [inaudible].
And that's the teleport, if Hamilton, Natan
[inaudible].
And more, I hit a little bit here a little bit then for MDs
and then Feemster
[inaudible] it's not your own today. It doesn't,
it depend Mary Solium faster.
And for him the few and ugly.
Hardware and set to do Apple.
Able to put on set.
[Inaudible].
Yeah,
[inaudible] the oxygen and the chemistry, our district taught
[inaudible] do it. The store for a ticker.
Just do for you or
[inaudible] [inaudible] or if, since on sock.
So if he's bought for sale at war for
the sleeve to toys and so on
[inaudible] [inaudible] and literally saved liquid new scale, you are the best
[inaudible], [inaudible] almost, you are the best I can
tell for sure.
Um, [inaudible].
What else had it leave it so normal. Oh, woman. Oh,
and if he's out in the lounge.
I suppose. Yeah.
[inaudible] just go from there. Um, yeah, I'm doing
[inaudible] um, this can be a fist bump
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].